do you think women want equality yes 100
yes yes 100 yes depends on a woman
okay okay okay okay okay so if that's
true if that's true why aren't there
marches for men to get free drinks and
get into bars for free if we want
equality
i don't know that is though what's that
really the girls can go in the tub yeah
if we drink why the men come to it
what because we're hot yeah
because are hot and we are not hooked
right but that's but that's right but
that's not equal we'll talk about equal
pay from like women and men sports a lot
right they always talk about that and
you get there's protests but there's no
protest for the men when they don't get
free stuff
well i think it just like balances it
out you know like they got so much more
only free drinks
how do how do men get more than women
when women have specific grants for just
being a woman and men don't
how how
how do men get more than women when
women have specific grants for just
being a women women and men
don't can i just say one thing about
women and men relationships they still
they still
the possession of the guy they he he
just wants to be the provider for the
goal
there's always going to be that because
that's that's what man feels like
but there's no question about it but and
that's why the man gets paid even more
in every job that the man does you can't
say that we don't work harder to be
honest
what do you mean that's [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] like let me be honest i work in
a construction site i work as a
construction worker how many women do i
have in my sight is none completely none
because women don't get higher than
construction women don't get hired for
construction
but most of them they don't so i have a
question i have a question for you okay
so if that's true if women can't get
hired for those jobs why in the
countries where women have more choice
do less choose to do jobs that pay more
so if you make a list of countries where
women are the most free and the least
free if you go to the most free
countries where women have the most
choice less of them pick jobs that make
more money i think it's because
i think it's because those are women
that have had more privilege in their
lives um i think if you go to places
where women don't have that much
privilege
like india cambodia places like that
women want to work women want to get
ahead i think here we have it easy
so maybe women don't choose to do that
yeah but i'm saying if women want to do
those things when they have the choice
to not work as hard more women pick
let's not work as hard i think most
people would choose not to work as hard
if given the option
so then what
but but but i'm saying
something very negative about guys guys
are too lazy to go to learn in school to
up to upgrade for their life
most of the guys they're lazy
i know because
it's not it's not that i know people
from our country i know people from a
lot of different countries they're just
too lazy to go and study when you don't
study
you can't be getting the jobs that the
girls get because the girls start
staying
but you realize men make more money than
women i do because is it possible that
men's shoes don't go to school as much
because their return on investment is
lower yeah that's why because the the
men they try and find
i'm like men
no i'm not on men or women's i'm not i'm
on the side of reality which women
ignore
because even right now like i'm giving
you these stats and numbers and i'm
saying like like in the choices where
women have the choice they don't choose
to do it and that's why there's a pay
gap but you still want to believe what
you believe
because i think that you're looking at
like
a specific example which and yes i agree
with that if i'm sure that there are
women many women who would choose not to
work if given the choice we're also
leaving behind the [ __ ] thousands of
women in underprivileged countries that
have horrible like working conditions
that need don't go to school
get you know like the guys get chosen
over them any day of the week and they
would give their lives to go to school
to get a good job so but how do you know
that because because
where do you where are you from
nicaragua like women want to go to
school like they want to go to [ __ ]
harvard they don't have the
opportunities
well to go to harvard
but i'm saying like like women don't
pick the hard job so like plumbing
electrician like construction on the car
we're talking wrong because i work in
construction myself and on my side i
have goals they do uh electrician and
plumbing as well but they're exceptions
they're not the rule that's what i'm
saying like like
women if you look at statistically those
those fields are 95 male 1 so you can
you could say that's an exception that's
an accession we're taught we're talking
about it depends it depends on the woman
if the woman wants to study to be a
plumber or electrician she can be but if
she if she wants to be a law to study
law or medical like that's an option
even even if even for male is the same
thing for example if i wanted to study
medical i would have studied medical if
i wanted to study
being a politician i would have done the
politician i just didn't choose to do
that life i chose to to make
my life harder for myself
for me i'm asking like what's in the way
of women in 2022
what's stopping us
[Music]
what rights do we not have
i would say one thing in england
the queen
is
[Music]
that's why
the woman and the men they're 50 50
because if the queen wasn't
in the palace
if he was a king it would have been
different what about the us i'm from the
u.s i know
have you seen donald trump i support
donald trump but have you seen him he
speaks like the the way the things are
it's bidet i know i know
now he's fighting
now he's by them but me personally i
like donald trump
but he speaks the fight